bella a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video io sono pari j
oggi siamo finalmente tornati su join
the grudge e il terzo episodio comunque
dato che non avevo registrato
gli episodi precedenti cioè no scusate
dato che non ho pubblicato l'episodio di
recente ho deciso che questo episodio
qui lo faccio più lungo del solito
quindi finiamo innanzitutto l'ospedale
dov'eravamo rimasti l'ultima volta e poi
se riesco faccio anche l'episodio dopo
adesso vediamo comunque dall'ultima
volta l'ho dovuto rifare tutto sono
ritornato qui e sono riuscite rapide
questa porta che non si apriva facendo
un casino che va beh non vi sto a
spiegare allora di sopra c'è una porta
chiusa
ho controllato soltanto fin là poi non
sono più andato avanti
come potete vedere adesso di batteria e
sto messo decisamente meglio
bene c'è un'altra porta identica a
quella dove siamo arrivati il perfetto
ok proviamo ad entrare
addio o cazzo ci sono dei capelli
ci sono dei cap questa è la nuova
pubblicità di garnier ok
bene ok non avevo intenzione di entrarci
comunque quindi andiamo al piano di
sotto fantastico no però mi spiegate ma
come cazzo fa ad avere di capelli così
lunghi c'è neanche io quando mi sveglio
la mattina lav e lasciamo perdere
scusate ragazze faccio dei tagli però in
the grudge avevo promesso che non
tagliamo più nel nei miei doma in the
grudge lo devo per forza fare perché
diciamo che il personaggio cammina come
un bradipo di 80 anni e quindi devo ok
c'è un'altra batteria perfetto è per
velocizzare devo tagliare per forza se
non ha gli occhi avanti alla batteria di
riserva
ok questa è l'ultima porta se non si
apre non so dove andare
ok pare che si che si apra attenzione
poiché adesso non volete essere
attaccato da uno sciame di capelli
partiamo già malissimo
ok non è successo niente però c'è una
porta che è letteralmente è stata
stuprata da dei capelli ma perché
ragazzi sono i capelli ci hanno la fobia
dei o dio poiché a [ __ ]
ok io mi ero stupito per prima
va bene ok allora io di solito non sono
merda che cazzo succede
ok
dicevo io non sono una persona che dà
peso a queste cose però dai un saltino
dal parrucchiere io lo farei se fossi in
te
vabbè lasciamo perdere andiamo avanti si
ritira la massa informe di capelli
mi consola il fatto che questa è l'unica
via dove posso andare perché poi non so
dove altro andare perché dato che ho
visto già tutto questa è l'unica o che
c'è una porta questo è proprio l'unica
via che mi manca quindi devo andare per
forza di qua e la cosa mi consola
tantissimo e io giustamente sto andando
nella porta dove arrivano sti capelli
maledizione cos'è sta roba mor morgue ok
non so che cosa vuol dire ma non importa
entriamo permesso dio mio no non c'è
niente zio ecco proviene ok raga
provengo che schifo
ok raga i capelli provengono dalla bara
maledizione paura ad aprirla nessuno ok
la bara non si apre ragazzi io torno
indietro
mortacci di cazzo di base di merda
bene la bara non si apre e io me ne va
cos'è sta roba droga cos'è non lo so
comunque c'è una chiave qui perfetto se
è così
chiave la chiave del tetto perfetto
adesso posso aprire anche la porta che
era chiusa prima
c'è soltanto la bara questa qui che non
si apre ma sinceramente non me ne frega
una minchia torno indietro c'è anche una
batteria perfetto
ok raga direi che posso tornare indietro
[Musica]
la bara non sia aperta e va bene così va
benissimo non mi interessava tanto cosa
c'era dentro guardate non era non era
diciamo il mio desiderio aprirla
ok perfetto dato che ci metterò tre ore
per tornare alla porta di prima faccio
che tagliare finché non ci arrivo perché
sennò possiamo stare così tre ore ok
ragazzi siamo allora adesso devo andare
a piedi ci sono le barelle possedute
merda
ok ti levi gentilmente dal caso grazie
tu vuoi farmi credere che non riesci a
spingere una barella porca put
vabbè lasciamo stare c'è ma non è che
devo tornare indietro kay forse riesco a
sì ce la fa ce la faccio merda staccavo
delle palle che mi no no no no no no no
no no no no no kat
merda no non applica aprirà una
lentissima porta aprile
ok a prima porta apri la porta a casa
si no maledizione devi aprire una bara
barella davis maledizione la barella
spingi spingi stava della libertà spingi
maledetto carola vai a prima porta
apri la porta ok abbiamo fatto no merda
chiudi ma che cazzo oddio lavati i denti
porca [ __ ] c'è un alito che uccide se
ho vinto ce l'ho fatta ce l'ho fatta ok
calmi ce l'abbiamo fatta
io lì dentro non ci torno più devo
andare al piano di sopra quello da dove
siamo partiti e devo salire le scale
taglio di nuovo prima che ci arrivo ci
metto secoli una palla che cazzo è
caduta una palla perché c'è una palla e
va beh l'asian perle che cazzo è mio dio
ma che cosa è stuprato un cestino ma che
cazzo è successo e quel bambino di merda
lo so che quel bambino di merda arriverà
una volta che lo prendono a calci quel
bambino di mer
succede al nuovo mitato sul soffitto
cosa ok
raga c'è una massa informe di capelli
che sì non lo so ma che schifo non so
neanche descrivere ma guest addio addio
c'è un tentacolo di capelli 6 un tenta
ok loschi oggi lo scriva ok allora io
fuori j versus tentacolo brutto stronzo
i capelli sono più lunghi 3d di
sorprendermi
ok sculaccia il mio maledetto pervertito
fallo ok ho vinto ho vinto io sono stati
tutti i capelli sono anche spariti ma
vabbè dettagli ok ci siamo allora ci ho
messo un'ora per salire le scale
ci siamo vero sì non c'è nessuno
perfetto l'ultima porta maledetta ok
spero che il livello sia finito qui
perché sta andando man mano che vado
avanti stato sempre peggiorando
allora ha permesso c'è qualcuno sarebbe
la giornata vero aspetto in ii che no
chi cazzo fa no non sto cazzo vabbè raga
lasciamo perdere e andiamo avanti qua
c'è un odio chi cazzo è quello c'è salve
le caduta la parrucca prima aveva i
capelli più lunghi adesso doveva le sta
andando maledizione ok è io devo dovrei
andare lì non è proprio l'idea raga io
ho paura ad andare
a proseguire prova avesse un'altra
barella speriamo che non sia posseduto
anche questa
ok si è fermato per come non detto cazzo
ok in certi casi sono veramente contento
di non essere su una barella però
lasciamo perdere andiamo avanti devo
infilarmi qua dentro no perché non ci
passo
devo andare di qua ok devo fare la
stessa fine dell'altro tipo di prima
cosa devo devi per forza guardare giù
vero no perché non sono non sei contento
salve
il botto che morbido no vero no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no
ok ok brutto stop
no non ti azzardare merda merda clienti
ok ok sono salgo sono salvo sono salvo
non era quasi ok ok tirati su tirati su
maledetto stronzo bravo bravo non puoi
fatte le fa vj bambino di merda non puoi
ok ci siamo ragazzi ci siamo tranquilli
è tutto a posto tutto ok tutto ok
non c'è nessuno però sentito rumori
una mano c'è una ma no merda
no no no no no no no piano no grazie
metti un cazzo di collirio anche no
merda no non ci credo
guarda sono contento che sia morta anche
tu almeno brutta troy lo luccica ma
ancora viva merda ok ok ok bene episodio
completato oggi una che che nasce dall
odio di chi è morto di morte violenta a
farci rojas pecora no tu hai il coraggio
di un leone i nervi d'acciaio
vorrei stai parlando fa vj qui è mica
con uno così a casa
vabbè lasciamo stare meglio che questa
mela evitavo perché come addosso io di
solito meglio che sto zitto
cos'è successo oggetti raccolti allora
frammenti di di foto e chiavi bene
indietro me ne frega un cazzo
sinceramente delle cose raccolte abbiamo
sbloccato un nuovo episodio appartamenti
disabitati ok raga
allora abbiamo finito il secondo
episodio quello dell'ospedale e come vi
avevo promesso adesso andrò a giocare
anche il terzo appartamenti disabitati
appunto per recuperare il tempo che ho
perso nel pubblicare del gregge perché
se no non avrei tenuto pil episodio ad
appartamenti disabitati ieri sono
veramente contentissimo di fargli
iniziare quest'anno questo nuovo
episodio senza sapere che cosa mi
troverò davanti è dato che ok ci siamo
allora sto passo quali talmente figo che
io volentieri ci passa rileva che tipo
di villaggi vacanze avete presente si
molto carino guarda a chernobyl
confronto e mirabilandia però lasciamo
perdere che c'è una una tessera allora
accidenti questa giornata non finisce
mai
minchia dubito che riusciva ad andare in
un ospedale a trovare mamma mamma mi sa
che non c'è più
bovo che deserto mancano solo gli zombie
pazienza faccio facciamo quello che
dobbiamo fare
guarda ken ok adesso siamo ken allora ok
siamo partiti ci sono delle scale adesso
tu mi spieghi che cazzo ci fa in un
posto così perché come hai fatto a
svegliarti qui allora
vabbè lasciamo perdere c'è un camion ok
io lo prenderei volentieri è però
evidentemente non si può fare quindi
andiamo avanti prima di finire le
batterie come nello scorso episodio raga
cerco di essere più sbrigativo stavolta
sempre se il personaggio principale non
scende le scale alla velocità di un
nonno di 95 anni
però a parte questo cercherò di essere
abbastanza sbrigativo ma vi rendete
conto di quanto cazzo è lento ma si può
vabbè lasciamo perdere
c'è qualcosa di lasi vedo già qualcosa
che spunta raga primo oggetto c'è
qualcosa laggiù non so che cosa
sinceramente c'è un parco giochi molto
ma molto
kat oddio ma che cazzo è successo è
crollata ok è crollata una trave no
veramente sono crollate 50 tra vino non
fa niente non posso tornare indietro
benissimo c'è in teoria potrei ma
presumo che lui non riesca a camminare
in mezzo ai cespugli quindi lasciamo
perdere
devo andare a prendere quella fare che
luccica sempre che io riesca a superare
sto ostacolo delle palme ok c'è una
palla che ha rimbalzato da sola è chiusa
quello a una luce niente niente niente
ok c'è una palla che ha rimbalzato da
sola ragazza non mi chiedete perché non
lo voglio neanche sapere c'è la sabbiera
ok
devo prendere la poco secondo una
batteria sia una batteria perfetto
iniziamo bene
ok batteria ci siamo è solo solo il
vento calmi ok
bene batteria di riserva siamo a 2 raga
già meglio di come abbiamo iniziato
perché stavo già a metà
devo riuscire a girarmi se riesco
perfetto madonna quanto laga scusate eh
l'emulatore rag e così la ga di solito
ok c'è qualcos'altro che luccica là in
fondo praticamente io passo livello a
cercare robe che luccicano porca [ __ ]
che è successo è una bambola e una
bambola caduta dal cielo tipo il def
noto ok bene non è che se scrivo il nome
di qualcuno sulla bambola muovere verona
raga e sud è la bambola più bella che
abbia mai visto in vita mia però non ho
proprio la necessità di prenderla
diciamo perché non è che sia così
contento e quindi faccio che andare
avanti che meglio c'è qualcos'altro qui
che poi ci vado c'è uno scivolo
veramente siamo passati da una fabbrica
abbandonata poi a un ospedale e adesso
siamo tipo chernobyl non sono anche dove
siamo però meglio lasciar perdere allora
andiamo avanti
adesso raga penso che inizierà diciamo
il pezzo pesante allora siamo a un altro
piano non è neanche l'ultimo qua ci sono
negli scatoloni ok
c'è una porta che stavolta non è
sbarrata e prova ad entrarci la porta
dove doveva entrare ok si è fermato
perchè si è fermato adesso ci entrò non
c'è bisogno che meno evidenti così
adesso ci entro
ho capito me lo dicono testimoni di
geova aprite buongiorno signora non le
mie intenzioni importunarvi però ok non
c'è nessuno
bene raga la porta si è aperta da sola
direi di entrare laga permesso non so le
scarpe sporche che bella accoglienza mi
tagliate una fetta di torta novero o
cazzo che è successo qui io ho veramente
paura ad andare a controllare qui dentro
che cosa ci può essere però devo raga mi
dispiace ma devo farlo
ok non c entro perché non riesco sono
troppo alto e non riesco ad abbassarmi
perché sono un vecchio di 95 anni che
non può piegare la schiena meglio così
ci sono dei coltelli a terra non
chiedetemi perché non lo voglio neanche
sapere arci qualcosa qui una chiaro che
è perfetto chiave del lucchetto quelle
lucchetti non ho trovato nessun oggetto
raga credo o dio terremoto merda merda
ok raga il terremoto non ci voleva che è
successo
porca [ __ ] che cazzo e lo scatolone
solo che è successo ma buttalo via sta
merda di scatola ce l'ho fatta
maledizione cosa era è una fumogena è
una granata fumogena ok
buongiorno sono entrato perché perché
dovevo ios merda non
ok salve buongiorno anche a lei mi offre
una fetta di torta aiuto ok ogni giorno
si le fa male la schiena faccio un
massaggio si vuole no sia caso ok sia
calma sia molto calma molto calma molto
calma molto calma vai via via chiudi la
porta
chiudi la porta però ho paura a girarmi
raga ho paura a girarmi ma che cazzo è
successo mi chiamati implodono i capelli
se c'è una cosa assurda
va bene va bene è meglio così noi
torniamo indietro ho trovato la chiave
del lucchetto che non so quale lucchetto
devo aprire ma l'ho trovata quindi va
bene
torniamo indietro ok siamo arrivati a
più salve guarda non lo so che cosa ti
ha detto la mamma ma non si gira nudi
per chernobyl la [ __ ]
cioè il classico scherzo dei bambini
sono al campanello e scappa c'è non era
proprio così me lo ricordavo però va
bene lo stesso
lasciamo perdere andiamo lì sotto ok ci
siamo ci siamo
ma chi sono questi salve svegli di prima
mattina e anche se proprio non c'è il
sole però vabbè sentite ho trovato una
chiave di un lucchetto
se qualcuno di voi è così gentile da
dirmi dove si trova questo lucchetto
madonna che scortesi bastava dire no
cioè non è che mi offendeva allora c'è
ancora la bambola c'è qualcos'altro che
luccica lì non ho visto prima ho trovato
la chiave ragazzo anche dove andare per
non ci parlo con voi tanto siete stronzi
non ci parlo ho trovato la chiave so
dove andarlo a mettere bene so che si
sta tutto brutto stronzo a tirare la
testa della bambola ma lasciamo perdere
che già mi state sul culo
ci sono le altalene che fanno avanti e
indietro e lasciamo perdere
c'è una batteria perfetto c'è una
batteria dove prima non c'era prima non
c'era la batteria non c'erano neanche le
mani però salve
stringerei la mano a tutti volentieri
però sono di fretta e devo prendere la
la batteria ok ok ok calmi ok bene la
palla e insanguinata è di dieta ma che
schifo ma che schifo
porca [ __ ] [ __ ] un bambino del
cazz cioè io ragalo sto bambino lo
detesto
ma perché sto bimbominkia deve rompere i
[ __ ] a me con tutta la gente che c'è
in sto posto non vedete che pieno che
poi ci metteresti due secondi a
scavalcare la ringhiera ma vabbè
dettagli lasciamo stare
apriamo stata nettissima porta
ok è permesso benissimo non vi
spaventate se ogni tanto vedete la la
scritta una scritta gialla lì sopra
perché indica semplicemente che sta
salvando la partita per poi non
riniziare tutto da capo
comunque c'è qualcos'altro che luccica
faccio che tagliare perché prima che
arrivo lì ci metto un ora che era che è
un'altra batteria perfetto allora
prendiamo in un attimo
ok siamo a 69 66 perfetto ma 5
anzi quattro e mezzo beh siamo a zero
raga c'è questa strada che l'unica che
mi rimane da percorrere per vedere un
altro edificio perfetto
io vado infilarmi si edifici nonostante
ci siano i bambini pallone e le le
ragazze con troppi i capelli o comunque
vado infilarmi si posti non chiedetemi
perché allora la porta è chiusa e per me
è soltanto un sollievo quindi andiamo al
piano di sopra
ok ci siamo ragazze un secchio
c'è un secchio che va bene rovesciato e
tutto il resto c'è sta roba che non mi
chiedete che cosa non ne ho la più
pallida idea
e poi c'è se riesce a girarti se c'hai
pure il torcicollo maledetto c'è una
chiave ma perché non riesce a girarsi
sto stronzo allora aspetta un attimo
ok non posso salire e posso soltanto
prendere la chiave che presumo apra la
porta di sotto quella che è
che prima non ero riuscito ad aprire ok
chiave stanza 202 ok andiamo a [ __ ]
maledizione
scendiamo subito via via via via via via
via via via via via via via via via
cos'è sta rumore perché ci sono le
impronte sul muro mio dio non si gioca
con gli acquerelli e neanche col
mantello dell'invisibilità di harry
potter però dio che cazzo succede perché
ci sono le manate sul muro non risco hai
tirato direttamente la secchiata
stavolta ma perché non riesco girarmi
porca [ __ ]
ce l'ho fatta ok ce la stiamo facendo
pian piano qualcuno me lo spiega poi ste
cose perché io non lo capite ma non
importa come del resto non ho capito un
cazzo di tutorial del gioco però
lasciamo perdere
non che il film fosse più diciamo
cristallino per dire però lasciamo stare
apriamo la porta
ok ci siamo faccio che salvare nel
frattempo è permesso
sono soltanto un povero vecchio che non
riesce neanche a girare la testa
ok ci sia allora le stanze sono tutte
molto simili
[Musica]
ok terremoto terremoto di poco key
piano che cazzo è successo
ok ma che cazzo è successo la porta miss
ok
raga la porta si è chiusa con i capelli
avanti senza le apro dopo perché la
porta è diciamo inagibile vabbè comunque
c'è cos'è sta roba
cos'è potrei sfondare sta roba per poter
uscire si volendo penso che lo potrei
anche fare ho sentito un rumore che non
so se me lo sono immaginato per che
cazzo
avanti
[Musica]
andric armadio l'armadio infilati dentro
nell'armadio infilati dentro
nell'armadio senza tirarsi
digitare non ci daremo tutti girare ok
piano
non c'è nessuno punta al cerchio con il
telecomando wii
ok ok bene c'è la bambina che fa avanti
indietro allora io ti consiglierei una
hai mai pensato di fare la polizia
faccia le 9
ma guarda che aiuta cazzo che schifo ma
ok ok se ne sta andando
se ne sta andando salviamo ok calmi non
è successo non ci posso credere non mi
sono preso un colpo
no no no no no no si ok io levo le tende
non piacere via via via via via
ma via via via via sfonda la porta
sfondata la dizione sfondare un capo di
legno bravo bravo così d'iniziativa vai
così alzati alzati accordi po arresto ok
siamo in piedi
c'era un qualcosa che luccicava lì
perché non l'ho presa
vabbè lasciamo perdere erano
probabilmente la gara una batteria che
ho dimenticato però la bambina che più
che bambina mi sembra il diavolo
reincarnato ma non importa
non mi ha permesso di prendere la
batteria sta stronza vabbè lasciamo
stare
decaduta la testa vabbè che cazzo ok
andiamocene prima possibile c'è un
sacchetto pieno di sangue che mi ispira
moltissimo si è mosso raga c'è c'è
sacchetto faranno al bel pattumiera
ok ragali l'invasione dei sacchetti
mutanti lasciamo perdere voi due non
fate parte della combriccola vero no
andiamo avanti
ok siamo arrivati ad un corridoio c'è
perché corridoio e una vietta non so
anche che cos'è
raga non mi chiedete dove sono perché
non so neanche dove sto andando cioè ok
si è fermato e c'è un'apertura anche lì
a sinistra che non promette bene e io
non ci entrerei però
se proprio devi fallo ok ho anche
salvato la partita perché non si sa mai
si è esplosa una luce ma che cazzo
succede sta esplodendo la luce vedo lo
iom io ce l'ho fatta ok
buongiorno si stai mi metto anch'io tipo
così ti vedo brillano no ti stai
utilizzando tu allora mi metto a posto
salve sei veramente sexy
ok via via via corri brutto stronzo
corretto scala il cavalletto no cosa fai
ti fermi fa che cazzo posso mai guidare
un ritardato così c'è ma veramente
lasciamo stare
cioè no no merda peggiore l'esorcista
raga rodio vestito verde si sta buttando
tipo bungee jumping però senza la corda
o che è ancora viva salve
il consiglio di farti la polizia
facciale io lo terrei sempre in
considerazione
vai via scala scavalca maledetto
deficiente vai bravo bravo bravissimo ti
devo fare devo darti premio nobel per
l'atletica anche se non esiste
ok ci giriamo è tutto tranquillo si è
tutto tranquillo che non ci sono calmi
praga è tutto un casino calmissimi ok
appuntano troviamo ok [ __ ] questa
non me l'aspettavo cazzo arrivo arrivo
su tranquilli ci sono chi sono
episodio completato ok merda o distrutto
tutto lasciamo perdere sicuramente sei
un fifone dov'è andato a finire o
spirito avventuroso tipico della rete ma
[ __ ] la tua possibilità ed è in realtà
un suo fascino minchia si vede che non è
ancora visto il video però lasciamo
perdere
eva bera che abbiamo concluso anche
questo episodio
spero che come ok cos'è il prossimo la
scrittura di un sorvegliante guarda io
so chi è questo sorvegliante ma l fa gli
faccio i miei più sentiti auguri a sono
io sono io nel prossimo episodio che
allora auguri favi per i prossimi
episodi
vabbè ragazzo amo stare
e però direi che per questo episodio
posso concludere qui spero che sia
passato come diciamo per farmi perdonare
per non averlo messo da secoli del
gregge
beh direi che posso chiudere qui se
riesco a trovare il telecomando che come
al solito lascio incastrato in mezzo
alla roba
vabbè se vi è piaciuto il video lasciato
un commento mi piace anche la pagina di
facebook e come solito trovate nella
descrizione di ogni mio video al se
l'episodio che è piaciuto l'ho già detto
questo quando gioca ste cose mi va in
pappa il cervello vabbè comunque se non
siete ancora i sinti scrivetemi noi ci
vediamo in un prossimo video bella
ragazzi